a lot of people ask me what I look for
in a supplement and to me it comes down
to three main things quality
transparency and third party testing
rituals multivitamin checks all the
boxes they're all about delivering
exactly what you need in highly
bioavailable forms rather than like a
hundred ingredients in non-clinical
dosages I use their Essentials for women
18 plus but I also use their prenatal
and post needle when I was in baby mode
but I am super super picky when it comes
to supplements and I like that rituals
backed by a visible supply chain with
rigorous third-party testing for heavy
metals microbes and allergens and they
share in-depth details on their
ingredients and why they're used so if
you want to try out ritual yourself you
can get 20 off of your first month using
my code a sharp 20 or go to ritual.com a
sharp20 let me know what you guys think